todos mesmo
muito lisonjeado mesmo por estar fazendo
parte desse evento
e na condição de pessoa com deficiência
a aap entrada já foi foi triunfal no já
mostra as dificuldades que as pessoas
com deficiência têm e vêm aqui num num
ano num evento tão de repente falar as
dificuldades que existem para as pessoas
com deficiência em nível de brasil e
principalmente no meu estado no rio
grande do sul onde há a discriminação é
bem mais aguda
creio eu já morei muito tempo fora do
rio grande do sul
e infelizmente nosso estado aqui tem uma
um conceito bastante agudo
então há a minha história eu chego aqui
[Música]
com a condição de uma das pessoas que
faz parte de um seleto grupo de pessoas
do mundo inteiro dos recordistas
mundiais a minha vida nem sempre foi
esse sucesso é o parto de uma família de
cinco irmãos onde o cotado para ser o
estouro da família era eu por causa da
deficiência e e felizmente o ícone da
família atualmente sonho sujeito que
aparece nas mídias sempre nos jornais
tudo por causa do esporte
então eu a história que eu conto é uma
história que eu não tirei de livro algum
a história da minha vida e em momento
algum eu gostaria que essa história
ficasse com a impressão para vocês que
uma história triste história de tristeza
muito pelo contrário
apesar de ser uma história de muitas
dificuldades
uma história com um com alguns alguns
alguns pontos bem bem agudos de
de tristeza é uma história de sucesso é
eu tenho convicção que ninguém ninguém
dessa platéia foi tão pobre quanto à
minha família a e e ter que passar
primeiro pela dificuldade econômica
depois pela dificuldade de mobilidade
reduzida e também pelo preconceito e
chegará a até o destaque nacional
interessante do internacional
foi uma longa jornada ah eu começo a
minha vida das coisas que eu lembro é
velado à infância da minha e do meu
questionamento por que eu não caminhava
como os outros e passa pela pela
adolescência onde na escola todos querem
namorar a menina bonita da escola querem
ser o capitão do time de futebol da
escola e eu tendo sempre o sendo sempre
sendo preterido pelas pessoas que
organizavam todo e qualquer evento no
cantinho espera aqui porque por causa da
condição física e eu chego a a
maturidade e encontro o sport e aí
começa a realmente aí eu realmente
começa a viver eu acho que até a minha
idade adulta a ao início da da da idade
adulta
foi um aprendizado para mim e aí começa
a viver é foi através de de do professor
aldo carlos patrício que é nome de rua
na cidade que o encontro o sport e foi
através do esporte é por causa do
esporte que hoje eu estou aqui não estou
aqui como
apenas uma pessoa com deficiência mas
sim por um grande atleta como eu fui bem
sucedido chegou ao livro dos recordes
o professor aldo me convida pra eu
pratiquei esportes e alcançou nele como
é pelo não conhecimento que infelizmente
ele toma conta do nosso país todo
o desconhecimento também na área
esportiva
eu tenho convicção de que poucos aqui
sabem de como é tão vasto universo do
paradesporto e eu colecionei professor
aldo como que uma pessoa desejada
poderia praticar esportes que era o que
na época todos os meus amigos a a
sociedade e dizia olha uma pessoa já não
pode mais com o sport e eles não o
esporte é praticado sintra às pessoas
com deficiência e apresentou esporte e
eu encontro a corrida de cadeira de
rodas eu fui apresentado a outros
esportes e ao encontro ocorrido em cada
12 horas
e aí a corrida em cadeira de rodas de
trás o que eu sempre almejei a liberdade
a liberdade onde as pessoas enxergava um
pedaço de borracha parafusos pedaços de
metal e enxergar as minhas pernas nem a
cadeira de rodas levou os quatro cantos
do mundo e voltar vitória extremamente
importante e levou pra uma página
inteira do new york times a maior jornal
do mundo e me levou para o livro dos
recordes o seleto grupo das pessoas que
fazem alguma coisa muito melhor do que
as outras e foi por causa dessa dessa
ajuda essa minha é esse meu reencontro
com a sociedade
eu somente estou aqui porque o porquê
uma mão foi estendida para mim ano
passado então
veja o quanto é importante um pequeno
gesto que às vezes as pessoas num não
valorizam tanto mas foi o jogo foi a mão
estendida do professor aldo que me
trouxe independência financeira que me
trouxe amigos nos quatro cantos do mundo
do planeta abriram inúmeras portas
também no terreno esportivo porque
queira ou não eu passei essa é uma
pessoa diferenciada não pela minha
condição de cadeirante mas pela condição
de atleta em seguida
é lógico que eu passo pelos percalços de
se buscar um patrocínio o sport
prazeroso para cadeirantes das pessoas
com deficiência em torno geral ainda é
muito caro é muito inacessível aqui no
brasil apenas produz travar para vocês a
uma cadeira de rodas de de que esteja um
preço médio assim custa em torno de 25 a
30 reais
então não são todas as pessoas que
dispõem dessa essa grama
então o carlão entra no esporte começa a
praticar o atletismo e se encontra com
as corridas de longa distância que era
onde eu realmente eu me sentia eu era o
vento batendo dá para ter a sensação de
liberdade
toda a liberdade que eu não tive
por causa da minha deficiência eu sentia
na cadeira de horas andando há há há com
muita velocidade
então ali foi a minha amiga realmente a
minha liberdade
então essa reflexão com o mundo saindo
lá da do estouro da família até chegar à
a inúmeros patrocinadores
eu tenho muito orgulho que um dos
maiores empresários da minha cidade é um
dia me viu treinando e perguntou quanto
custava colocar a logomarca dele no meu
capacete e é um sujeito muito bem
é o sucedido na cidade aqui e isso me
massagear o ego porque quer um trabalho
sério era um trabalho bonito e é um
trabalho efetivo que ele estava
precisando porque ele em momento algum
ele que ser assistencialista coitadinho
do aleijadinho não ele tem até hoje um
olhar muito aguçado para o negócio e ele
enxergou ali também uma fonte de
marketing
o negócio dele é ilusão nilson jogou
muito essa peça fala dele no sport eu
cheguei aonde cheguei nesse desafio que
eu que eu fiz 24 horas a a prova não é a
correr as 24 horas sem parar
a prova é em 24 horas qual é a maior
descansa atendido a atingido e eu
atingir 240 quilômetros em 24 horas
é realmente uma uma marca bastante
considerável e foi feito um trabalho
muito grande em cima disso e sem o
auxílio do staff
então aí que eu digo sempre para a
sociedade
quando isso em todos os segmentos não só
na das pessoas com deficiência
há inúmeras vezes a gente diz assim
ninguém faz nada então está na hora da
gente poder fazer alguma coisa por
alguém porque no meu caso é uma mão
estendida transformou um sujeito
transformou um conceito e e certamente
eu tenho uma legião de seguidores do meu
trabalho do meu esporte eu tive eu e meu
primo muito pela perfeição então tudo
que eu faço é eu não gosto de fazer
coisas ruins ou feias porque eu gosto é
assinar tudo que eu faço então
1 se eu fizer alguma coisa feia ou ruim
não foi assinado mas as coisas que eu
faço eu sempre gosto de assinar e eu
tive alguns ídolos na minha vida
pessoas totalmente acima da média como
eu determinados um dos meus ídolos
chama-se oscar schmidt então chamavam os
carros de mão santa não num de santo não
tem nada não tinha eu o que o que existe
sim era um treinamento
o oscar schmidt era um sujeito que ele
chutava 3 mil bolas em direção à cesta
buscando acertar ecológico
depois do treino oscar schmidt o amor
dele pelo país dele pela seleção é
impediu que ela escapasse milionário e
fosse jogar na liga americana
então pra mim é um é um exemplo eu
sempre sempre seguir o modelo dos casos
de como levar a sério o esporte nessa
nessa minha caminhada eu também
encontrei não não não só esse grande
empresário que que me acenou com a mão
mas inúmeras inúmeras portas fechadas
então quando eu digo pra vocês que que o
estado do rio grande do sul é um 12 é o
estado mais preconceituoso é eu eu
iluminou com uma conversa que eu tive
por exemplo como empresário daqui de
porto alegre no ramo da moda e tem uma
cadeia de lojas em que ele me disse que
a proposta era colocar uma estampa vinha
correndo e dizer eu apoio esse atleta e
[Música]
ele disse não eu não vou não vou fazer
isso eo ea colocar essas suas camisetas
das lojas para ser vendido reverter em
dinheiro
ele não não vou colocar ela estampa
porque nenhuma pessoa em sã consciência
quer levar um aleijado no tempo
então ele se hoje a um metro e meio de
distância e depois um outro que
trabalhava no no segmento de de seguros
detida de convênios com com saúde
seguros saúde enfim também me disse a
mesma coisa eu não posso vincular a
imagem de uma pessoa arranjado porque eu
vendo saúde
mal sabia ele que o sujeito que estava
falando ele correu a maratona baixo duas
horas
então esse esse é um estado que que qq e
em inúmeras outras portas das quais a
fatia que que tive as pretensões
frustradas em busca de patrocínio
então eu tenho um reconhecimento eu
tenho há alguma penetração muito maior
fora do meu país do que no meu país eu
trabalhei num grande jornal na redação
do grande jornal de porto alegre e no
ano de 2001 eu venci a maratona de nova
york eo new york times me deu três
quartos de página e um dos quartos de
página não saiu com mais matéria porque
o empresário porque o alguém do
marketing do do jornal vendeu para um
para um para o empresário e ofereceu
para vários empresários
aquela matéria e um empresário comprou
esse um quarto de página para ele
aparecer junto com a matéria porque ele
tinha idéia de que a a a matéria era
pungente e no jornal no qual eu
trabalhava
demorou mais de uma semana pra sair
alguma coisa inclusive foi descoberto
que o descoberto que eu havia ganho a
maratona em nova york pela editoria de
mundo a editoria de mundo que lê os
jornais
todo mundo leu que um gaúcho de porto
alegre tinha havia ganho a maratona de
nova york
eles puxam aqui o nosso colega eu vou
convidar vocês pra assistir dois vídeos
e para uma reflexão a do que o que move
realmente as pessoas a buscarem os
objetivos o que move o que é quando você
é é colocado num balaio de gatos a o
joão não pode fazer tal coisa porque ele
tem cabelo curto alan não pode fazer tal
coisa porque ela é um mulherão a enfim
então a quando não dizem para as pessoas
que existem limites
as pessoas têm tem um outro pensamento
da vida gostaria que vocês a apreciassem
comigo são dois vídeos bem rapidinho
apenas como reflexão eu acho que vai
apagar esta semana em caio
isso é o campeonato é a paraolimpíada
e a gente vê ali na barra da baliza 5 o
tal que um chinês
quando eu chegasse aqui serve pra vocês
que eu tenho um amigo que não tem os
braços e quero que ser nadador fez
porque sujeito está fazendo ela é nada
legal tem que enfrentá estimado e foi
inventado por ele ele desenvolveu isso é
o que o sujeito não tem os braços que
nadando e essa é foi um vídeo lei que
contempla as diversas frentes
a deficiência foi criado pelo comitê
britânico - disse fh ikea ou seja sim eu
posso
e no momento quase no final
ele viveu ele aborda o mercado de
trabalho de vocês
em geral as pessoas com limitações
bastante grave
bastante relevante praticando esporte
devendo
demonstrando e a pessoa mesmo com
deficiência
ele tem um mercado aberto inclusive na
escola
tá aqui há muito
[Música]
e assim é que é
e essa mãe o que é isso ai que viajariam
um avião com a mulher sem braço e é só
quero um ps que eu falei pra vocês
infelizmente não
no rosto e eu só quero
ó o jogo
[Música]
os rapazes e faz parte do círculo de um
circo circo mais famoso do mundo de
a provar-se tudo por causa que não
disseram para ele colocar na cadeira de
rodas não disseram pra ele pra quê
cirurgia
então ah ah ah ah ah ah eu certamente
tem convicção de que aqui na platéia
existem histórias tão interessantes
o mais interessante que a minha mas é
importante contar las e e e é
extremamente importante é extremamente
importante
quando é uma pessoa tem alguma alguma
limitação independente dela seja física
emocional que ela tenha algum bru não
coitadismo assistencialismo mas ela
tenha alguém onde é o de se apoiar
então nós estamos num mundo em que nós
estamos de de tanta individualização de
de tanta capitalização a gente enxergar
o que existe de mais mais caro que a
vida não e eu chego ao final da fala
dizendo para vocês que o tudo o que eu
fiz não foi querendo ser o carlão e se
do guinness book
eu apenas queria dizer eu acho que a
minha vida porque a corrida para mim é
um estilo de vida
então eu eu queria crianças vivem só de
ver queria participar com os amigos de
corrida com está correndo tal
infelizmente uma pessoa estendeu a mão e
depois outro depois aqui depois outra e
eu um estorvo da família por causa de
uma mão estendida
foi melhor na rua onde o melhor da
família pois o melhor da rua foi o
melhor da cidade melhor do estado melhor
do país
o melhor do mundo tudo por causa de uma
mão estendida
então num não se envergonha de estender
uma mão que ela pode estar muito longe
dali trazendo frutos que vocês nem
imaginam professoral do portsmouth
eu tenho há pachorra de dizer que não
teve não tinha a capacidade de mensurar
a onde chegaria aquele aperto de mão
dele é eu eu fui criado pela minha avó
ea minha avó sempre zelou pela para que
eu tivesse uma boa conduta
então se fosse a minha conversa que teve
algum pontinho de inspiração pra vocês
ela vai ficar muito feliz se ela serviu
de inspiração para você não vai ficar
mais realizado
e se por acaso alguém tiver como modelo
eu tenho certeza que vai explodir de
felicidade era isso que eu tinha provas
é